607 new this morning the las vegas  housing market is setting even more  records  this morning las vegas realtors reports  the median price for an existing  single-family home sold in june  395 thousand dollars up ten thousand  dollars from may  and an incredible twenty one and a half  percent from june of last year  median price for a condo or a town home  sold in june 216 thousand dollars that's  up fifteen point four percent from last  year  las vegas realtors says a low supply of  available homes is fueling these price  hikes  and now they're seeing even more  investors jumping in  they're buying homes they're turning  them into rentals for  folks that cannot afford to buy a home  neat